pretty
okay so welcome to the talk
so I'm presenting our paper at ECS whose
title is a new conjecture or on harness
of two csps with implications to the
densest K sub graph and other graph
problems
I'm jihantan from from Rutgers
University and this is based on drawing
work with Julia Detroit from ttic Mina
daddy Rayford from Ms mmt and Vadim
Greenberg from Wiseman Institute of
science
okay so in fact the statements of the
main results in our paper are somewhat
long and hard to memorize so very high
level takeaway is that we proposed our
conjecture on two csps that can be seen
as occupying a middle ground between the
previous contractor not two csps and it
also implies a harness of approximation
results of the density subgroup problem
that also lies in the Middle Ground
harness of result between in previous
works okay and our conjecture also
implies connecting the harness of some
other growth problems
okay so it's a very high level message
so what is this density subgroup problem
for the sdks problem the input is a
graph which is a set of vertices and set
of edges connecting them and also in
integer K okay so for example this is
the input graph and K is 10 okay and the
goal is compute a subset of vertices
that contains exactly K of the vertices
in the graph while the number of edges
between these K vertices are maximized
okay so for example in this instance the
input graph is on the left and input
into the case 10 and optimal solution is
what lies within this orange circle okay
so orange circle contains 10 vertices
and the optimal solution cost is 19
meaning that there are a total of 19
edges connecting them
okay so this is K sub graph is sort of
one of the most basic graph optimization
problems that has been studied
extensively okay however despite all
this extensive work the understanding of
its approximate of its approximability
is still quite incomplete okay so to
date the best current approximation
algorithm due to bhaskara in 2010 only
achieves a until the 0.25 plus Epsilon
approximation into the old one or
episode Time
okay so this is best approximation
result and the best harness of
approximation proof is also very Elusive
and the most previous result depends on
various complexity conjectures
for example if again in 2012 shows that
we cannot get a one plus Epsilon
approximation if refuting random three
set is efficient
okay and subset code in 2002 shows that
we cannot get one plus Epsilon
approximation if the class MP does not
belong to the intersection of all these
d-time classes okay and some stronger
harness result due to the right camera
2010 they show that a super constant
harness of a plug approximation can be
proved assuming the famous small set
expansion conjecture okay and alone
until in 2010 shows that also a steel
per constant harness of approximation
proof If reviewed in random now K and
formulas is inefficient okay and for
some stronger conditional harness
condition on stronger complexity
assumptions alone tour in 2010 shows
that 2 to the Omega log into the two
thirds
like hardness of approximation if the
planted click problem is hard okay and
in the recent Breakthrough by many runs
in 2017 it showed that assuming the eth
contractor so exponential time
hypothesis
then the problem is hard to
approximation hard to approximate within
factor into the Omega one over poly log
log n okay so that's uh almost a
polynomial approximation the hardness of
approximation okay so our results also
our first main results also falls into
this conditional harness category okay
specifically we propose a new conjecture
on two csps and show that if the
conjecture is true then it is NP hard to
approximate the dks problem to within
factor to to the log into the app store
for some small constant Epsilon okay so
this factor is essentially into this one
so it is smaller than any polynomial but
it's larger than any poly log n okay so
our harness results can be seen as
occupying a middle ground between the
previous simple constant balance and
near optimal near near polynomial
balance okay so it is Middle Ground
conjecture
so
our second group of results shows the
approximation equivalence between the
problem dks and some other graph
problems they are maximum bonding
Crossing subgraph density coloring and
Rh color Okay so let's look at each of
these problems separately so in dense K
graph a dense K column problem the input
is a graph of an integer K and the goal
is to partition the vertices of the
input graph into roughly n over K groups
of size k each okay and the goal is to
maximize the number of edges with both
endpoints lying in the same group
okay so that's similar to the density
subgraph problem in the sense that in
the density sub graph the goal is to
compute a single dense subgraph of G
containing K vertices
and in the density coloring problem we
need the partition g into many then sub
graphs each containing most K baronesses
okay exactly K areas is each okay
so the second problem is Rh graph
coloring
okay so the goal is the input is a graph
G and integers R and H and the goes to
compute R vertex destroying sub graphs
H1 to HR of G maximizing the sum of the
number of edges in it truncated at age
okay so this problem is also similar to
the dks problem as it is due in the
spirit of computing many vertex disjoint
then subgraphs of a Degreaser graph okay
so last one is called maximum bounded
Crossing subgraph
okay the input is a graph G and the
integer L and the goal is to compute a
sub graph h of G with the Crossing
number of the subgraph being smaller
than H being smaller than L okay while
maximizing the number of edges in the
subgraph that we compute
okay so it is actually a variant of the
famous Crossing number problem whose
approximal ability remains wide open
until recently it is a subpoinomial
factor approximation on the boundary
degree graphs okay that is irrelevant
but it is just to say that this is a
variant of the famous Crossing number
problem okay so this very last problem
maximum bonding processing subgraph it
looks like irrelevant to the dks problem
on the surface but in fact they are all
closely related to another Central
problems in routing called the no
destroying paths problem
okay so specifically they are all
mentioned in the recent work by to Joy
Kim animal out in 2012 2021 stock
which shows that almost polynomial
harness of approximation result for NDP
assuming some conduction okay so it is
actually a conditional harness result
okay
so in particular their work shows that
no destroying path problem is at least
as hard as the RH graph coloring problem
okay
and they are writtenly wanted to prove
that the RH coloring problem is hard but
they did not like manage to do it and in
fact they only managed to show a
conditional harness result for a
specific variant of the RH graph
coloring problem which is still
fortunately valid for a reduction to NDP
so they show a conditional harness
result for RH graph coloring a variant
of it and then reduce NDP to it that's
how they improve the conditional almost
polynomial harness of results
for a no digital problem okay and our
work shows that conditional harness
result for dks and dks as it is
equivalent in approximation to all these
three problems RH coloring density
coloring the maximum bonded sub Crossing
subgraph
we also show exactly a connection on
harness of harness of approximation
result unless the RH graph quality
problem so we sort of achieve their
original goal
okay so this is like the second group of
result it is showing that these problems
are equivalence in approximation and we
will not go into the details as problems
or how to prove the equivalence between
them but roughly speaking the
equivalence results shows that if one
problem has a alpha and like
approximation then the other problem
like the other one of these three
problems has either a O Alpha
approximation or o f n square or O Alpha
like a bracket is some quasi polynomial
in Factor here okay so these are not
exact preserving approximation but
roughly they're all the same and one
like one has a two to the login to the
Epsilon approximation as stated in the
conjecture then all other three has the
same like order of approximation
algorithm
okay so this is the equivalence in
approximation results
okay so in the remaining time I will
focus on the new conjecture and briefly
show how it implies the harness for the
dks problem
right
the conjecture is called D2D by parthead
to CSP connector
okay where CSP stands for the constraint
satisfaction problem
so what is a bipartisan CSP
so the input is
two sets of variables like denoted by
big X and Big Y respectively and a
alphabet a where the variables in X and
Y takes values wrong okay and There's a
constraint there's a set of constraints
C
okay and the goal is to find assignment
like for each variables in X and Y we
assign the value from a to it okay and
we want this assignment to satisfy as
maximum number of as large number of
constraints in C as possible
okay so maximizing number of satisfied
constraints Satisfied by this single
assigned
okay
so
um specifically the constraints can be
organized into a graph called constraint
graph okay so constrain each constraint
like concerns one variable small X in
big in X and one variable in y okay
that's why it is called why it's called
two csps every constraint concerns two
variables
and why it's called biparton it is
basically because the constraint graph
can be organized into a bipartic graph
where the left vertices corresponds to
the small uh like variables small X in
big X and vertices on the right
corresponds to variables in y okay and
there's an edge between the small X and
small y like if and only if there's a
constraint in the constant collection C
the concerning this pair of variables
okay so now for each constraint we also
need to specify what it means for it to
be satisfied okay so this brings us to
the assignment graph associated with
this constraint okay so recall we need
to assign each variable in X and Y a
value in alphabet a okay which is for
now a set of colors here okay the red
green brown purple and yellow okay so
for a constraint C concerning variables
small X and small y
the assignment graph contain two sets of
nodes
hey the set of nodes on the left instead
of nodes around right okay where a left
right node
represent the assignment that the small
variable X
takes color red okay and a right green
node represents the assignment that the
small y takes the color green
okay an edge in the graph is basically a
truce table for the constraint
meaning there's a net between the left
red and the right green if and only if
when the assignments assign small X to
red and Designs more white green this
constraint is satisfied
okay so this is the definition of this
uh bipartite 2sp CSP and what it means
to like the graph has a constraint graph
and assignment graph for each constraint
okay so this is the definition of DSP
and typically for csps we focus on the
so-called Gap problem
okay
so we're given two constants C and S
called completeness parameter and the
soundness parameter of both between 0
and 1. and we want to know that if at
least C fraction of the constraints can
be satisfied simultaneously by an
assignment or no more than as fraction
of these constraints can be satisfied by
any single assignment if we are promised
that one of these possibilities will
happen
okay so this is called a gap CSP problem
okay and usually there are two
parameters characterizing the feature of
this CSP which we call D and D Prime
okay so typically in previous work we
say that a CSV is D to D Prime if and
only for each constraint in its
assignment graph degree of every left
vertex are exactly D and the degree of
every right vertex are exactly D Prime
okay so I want to remark that it is in
most previous work it has D equal to D
and equal to D Prime degree as required
however in our new contracture to
represent later we only require the
degree to be less than D and less than D
Prime and we also call it a d to D CSP
okay so the most famous setting is the
unit game setting which is essentially
One to One games
so in other words for every constraint
the assignment graph corresponding to
this constraint is a perfect matching
okay and the famous unique game
conjecture proposed by a code in 2012 it
states that for all constant Epsilon
there exists a alphabet size a such that
the one minus Epsilon App Store Gap CSP
problem is and be hard for any games
okay so SMP complete it's NP hard to
detect whether a input in a game is like
at least 36 viable or at most as
satisfiable for this one minus Epsilon
Epsilon combination of Cs values
and it also proposed a related D21
conjecture which said that for all
Epsilon D there exists a alphabet size a
such that the one app store Gap csps MP
hard for D2 and csps okay now the
complaint is need to be perfect this
contraction so one app store instead of
one minus Epson Epsilon
so our conjecture states that for all
Epson now smaller than 0.5 okay
and for there is this combination of
parameters D and S where D equals 2 to D
log into the App Store and S equals 2 to
the minus log into the 0.5 plus Epsilon
okay so this combination of parameters
which are both until one okay so sub
polynomial such that the Gap CSP okay so
this combination of kfcsp
SMP hard for this D2D csps
okay so this is our conjecture this
parameter combination so apart from this
different parameter combination there
are two other differences between our
conjecture and the old ones okay one we
do not need the completeness to be
perfect or almost perfect okay so
originally there's one plus Epsilon here
and One Max Epsilon here and one here
and we only require it to be 0.5
okay this is significantly lower okay
and second we post no restriction on the
alphabet size a okay so previously it
says there exists alphabetes which may
depend on App Store okay and there's an
alphabet size make depends on Epsilon D
and we post no constraints here okay and
part of it is because that our D okay is
already depending on N so it's two to
log into App Store so as the size of the
CSP is almost m d is also a factor a
function of n a can be just most bounded
by n as well so it cannot grow
arbitrarily large compared with and also
compared to SD so that's sort of not
necessarily good
okay so this is our conjecture
and uh one remark one remark about our
conjecture is that it can also be viewed
as occupying a middle ground between the
D21 contractor by code and the proof of
the hardness of approximation proofs
that can be achieved by standard
techniques like for example three cfts
and together with parallel repetition
okay so specifically if we use the
standard techniques like proving
hardness constant harness result of csps
via parallel repetition we can prove
some slightly weaker version of the D2D
character which requires an evenly
bigger D here
okay and what we are conducting is sort
of stronger than that okay we required
you to be this small factor which is
like now
um outside out of the scope of the power
reached by the standard techniques okay
so in this sense our conjecture is also
a middle ground conductor between D21
conjecture and standard techniques
so uh at the very end I would like to
briefly sketch how to prove the
connection or harness result of the
density K subgroup problem basically
assuming the conjecture is true we want
to show that it is MP hard to
approximate the dks problem we see in
Factor two to log into the App Store
and we are going to prove by
contradiction so we assume that there
exists a totally log into the absolute
approximation algorithm for this this
case subgraph problem which we denote
about ALG in red and we want to use this
algorithm to prove the D2D gain or to
solve the D2D game certifying whether or
not it is an es instance or no okay so
largely satisfiable or very lightly
satisfiable
how we're going to do it
recall that a CSP contains a constraint
graph and for each constraint and
assignment graph okay so we will first
constrain construct one Global
assignment graph as follows okay so we
replace each variable X in the
constraint graph by an assignment Gadget
okay for example X is the variable on
the left so it's a variable in the big X
set and now we replace this node with a
gadget which contains basically one node
representing each element in a and so if
a is still a collection of colors then
it is just a five colors in a within
this gadget
and a small red node here still
represents the assignment being
assigning red to X okay let's do this
meaning
okay and on top of that we planned for
each constraint its assignment graph
Just Between the corresponding two
gadgets
okay so basically uh we have a
assignment graph here and it is between
two collection of a elements and now we
have it here and we just plant a plant
the graph here
okay
so we do the same for other constraints
okay and we call the resulting graph a
global assignment graph okay and what we
do next is to basically apply this
approximation algorithm ALG for a
density subgraph to this graph okay the
the key intuition is that if the CSP is
a yes instance meaning that a large
fraction of this constraint can be
satisfiable by a single assignment then
there exists a dense X Y X Plus y size
subgraph
corresponding to this good assignments
in that most natural way so for example
if the in this assignment X takes value
takes the color green then we basically
pick this vertex
okay and if the Y small y takes the
value of graph then we just pick this
vertex and we picked all the
corresponding vertex this gives us a X
Plus y subset okay and if the if there
are many constraints that can be
satisfied by this assignment then like
basically there are a lot of edges
corresponding to this assignments two
stable edges okay and this is sort of a
dense graph for us
okay this is basically the intuition how
the conjecture can be related to dks
problems and due to the time limit I'm
now going to more details the real
algorithm is much more complicated than
this framework has shown for example on
one honey will consider the possibility
that how a cheating then sub graph may
look like okay and we are in fact not
constructing one graph and render
algorithm once but we will constantly
decompose the graph into smaller pieces
and recursively run the approximation
graph on each of them and then do
something else okay and also there are
many pre-processing steps that are
needed in each iteration okay so it's a
whole iterative algorithm it's a good
type reduction
so that's basically it it's uh basically
hopefully it shows some intuition of how
like this D2D conjecture can apply the
harness of approximation result for D
cash problem
and that's basically uh the the end of
the talk and just a quick summary and
future directions we proposed a new
Middle Ground due to the conjecture on
2csps which implied Middle Ground
harness or inflation result for the ssk
that's the case of graph problem and
both middle ground and I mean internet
of one it's between some simple constant
and some almost polynomial okay and
future reduction maybe just approve it
maybe some tax some techniques in the
recent breakthrough that proves two to
two conjecture may help proving this
conjunction
okay so that's all I want to say today
and thank you for your attention